this video was made possible by tab for
a cause if you are a subscriber to this
channel you are a legal eel that means
you want to know how the laws that
govern our everyday lives actually work
you know that the world is complicated
and you're not willing to settle for the
easy answers that pundits love to
provide you believe that understanding
the law is crucial to being an informed
citizen and you are not willing to turn
away even when you get answers that you
don't like you're here to think like a
lawyer so my fellow legal eagles in 2019
I say to you
taka and if you're looking for more
killer legal analysis I thought it might
be helpful to make a list of the five
best attorneys to follow in 2019 fair
warning this list is gonna be pretty
politics heavy because I think that
those are some of the most important
legal issues of the day maybe that will
change in 2020 but that's where we are
now so let's start out with an honorable
mention who is not actually a lawyer but
whose legal analysis is so good that I
almost included him on this list and
that's been witness of the law fair blog
he's not a lawyer he's a little bit on
the conservative side but in my view
nobody knows more about national
security law on the internet today and
as mr. Witness likes to point out
democratic norms are being broken all
over the place in this current world
that we live in but it's bringing people
together from all over the political
spectrum
I share mr. witness's request that when
this is all over everyone remembered the
shared democratic principles that
brought us together in these trying
times so definitely check out Ben with
us and the entire law fair blog and
podcast community they are great
so that brings us to fifth place for the
top lawyers to follow in 2019 and that
goes to Leonard French moving away from
politics for the moment as your second
favorite copyright attorney I can highly
recommend your first favorite copyright
attorney
Leonard French Leonard French is a
copyright attorney and youtuber known
for wearing funny hats while he gives
great legal analysis
he tends to livestream before he goes to
work so you can catch him early in the
mornings or late at night he often goes
straight into the legal briefs of famous
copyright cases or other legal cases of
the day and it's great because you
rarely get a chance to see the actual
language and paperwork that gets filed
in these things and he provides great
analysis his YouTube channel the lawful
masses with Leonard French is great for
copyright news of the day especially for
video game related news it's a little
wonky but that's how we like it here so
that takes us to fourth place and that
goes to Seth Abramson he is a former
state and federal public defender
there's going to be a lot of assistant
US attorneys and district attorneys on
this list so it's nice to get the
perspective of a public defender
currently Seth Abramson focuses on the
Trump administration and all of the
legal issues that the administration is
facing he gets a lot of flack for not
doing original reporting and for being
extremely long-winded like Twitter
threads that are hundreds of posts long
and fair enough but for my money
no one is examining the publicly
available evidence in more detail than
Seth Abramson note however that he tends
to be extremely partisan so I would take
all of his analysis with a grain of salt
maybe dial it back 25 or 30 percent but
still when new cycles don't even last 24
hours we need someone to be able to cull
through the deluge of news that we're
getting every day and look at things
from a lawyer's perspective and a lot of
the analysis that Seth Abramson is doing
is really top-notch
all right so that takes us to third
place and that goes to two lawyers
Renato Mariotti and Asha ranga who are
often hosts of the on topic podcast i
mentioned both because while the podcast
is renato maryani's he often has Asha
Ranga on and frankly the podcast is
never better than when she provides her
analysis as well both are former
assistant US attorneys which essentially
is like a district attorney but for the
federal government
Renato worked on the civil side while
Asha worked on the counterintelligence
side so their analysis together is
especially invaluable you can also find
both of them on Twitter but they're also
not afraid to do an emergency podcast to
stay on top of this news cycle that is
burying people in new things every
single day so definitely check out the
on topic podcast so that takes us to
second place and that easily goes to
Preet Bharara who is the host of the
stay tuned podcasts and tweets at Preet
Bharara Preet Bharara was in charge of
the Southern District of New York which
is often considered one of the most
prestigious federal district courts not
only does the Southern District of New
York tend to handle a lot of
high-profile terrorism related cases
because of the fact that New York City
is in a Southern District of New York
they also tend to handle almost all of
the very high-profile financial crimes
by virtue of Wall Street being in the
Southern District note that he was a
Democratic appointee who was personally
fired by the President so you'll
probably need to take his analysis with
a grain of salt but I think he is one of
the best interviewers on the planet
right now you cannot miss his podcast
so that takes us to number one and that
goes to Ken white who tweets at PO Pat
and is in charge of all the president's
lawyers and the First Amendment podcast
make no law Ken white is a former
assistant US attorney turned defense
attorney who's also done a fair amount
of First Amendment law he also has a
very skeptical view of government and
prosecutorial power which I find makes
his analysis both accurate and hilarious
it's hard to describe just how good ken
White's Twitter account is it is I think
by far the best thing on Twitter right
now so if you're not following at Pope
hat on Twitter stop everything you're
doing and subscribe now sometimes is
hard to follow him because his handle is
always some variation of hat so at the
time of this video its hamburger hat
which is relates to a president's tweet
in the past has been Kofa a hat very
legal and very cool hat his podcast all
the president's lawyers in addition to
having the greatest name for a podcast
is fantastic it's hosted by journalist
Josh Barrow who does a great job playing
the straight man to ken White's legal
analysis and breaking things down from a
layman's perspective when I do a podcast
I'm gonna try and make it half as good
as all the president's lawyers ken white
is known for taking a very dim view of
the RICO statutes please tell him to
make a it's not Rico t-shirt because
it's not Rico it's never Rico but maybe
this time cacao so go and check out
those lawyers and while you're browsing
the net you can raise money for charity
just by opening new tabs which you were
going to do anyway tap for a Cause is a
Google Chrome extension that allows you
to pick a charity of your choice and
then every time you open up a new tab
instead of it being blank it displays a
couple of ads and the money that you
generate is donated to your charity
there is no charge to you and it does
some good for the world tab for caused
users have raised hundreds of thousands
of dollars for charity it is the easiest
possible way to donate to charity so
just click on the link in the
description and download the extension
and do some good by doing what you were
going to do anyway so did I get that
right are there other lawyers that you
follow that you think I should also
follow in 2019 let me know and until
next time I'll see you in court